nakaya's the depressed Loza Luna girl -
calcio Dion estrellas move OTF Galleria
tibias Cairo Priam when enoguh Strasburg
Mota yes er strata yellow Utica TV - ah
hwacha sir
it is not just watch Oprah Conchita and
I passed a and macario's todos come to
study be near Stowe's reduce a week but
Hamas 13 is mostly a Yoba no padam is
some ECB specialty d'Afrique on sheet
yeah by co-edited reporter Castillo let
us play a Swanson thing Isabel
stretchers your companion route via
organic used a TPS Lucia Miyavi martin
la misma muchas Licinius Incubus care by
a Tomoya should keep Laputa ET spirit
initiate lannister guest we marked ishka
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play penumbra necro
log now if you go back way in time and
markiplier history one of the second
games of one of the second game I ever
played was penumbra overture and then I
came after that was penumbra Black
Plague now the penumbra series is a game
that was made before amnesia by
frictional games and it is obviously an
older game but these guys who are
modders of Russian descent are trying to
recreate the essence of the game in a
new mod and this is just the demo of it
but it seems to be very very well done
so let's get into it now it has been a
long time since I touched anything to do
with penumbra there was penumbra
overture first a penumbra
it doesn't give any light anymore
penumbra Black Plague after that which
in my opinion was scarier than overture
overture mainly relied on the atmosphere
of the game but in essence they are
still very similar now I don't know what
I'm looking for but I won't leave
without my backpack okay anyway I saw
that yamimash was playing this so is
that okay I saw that yamimash was
playing this
and oh man it has been a long time since
I even thought about penumbra I mean
it's one of my favorite series that I've
ever done I mean I thoroughly enjoyed it
wait a minute oh that wasn't there
before they said don't think it was
oh hello hi hello if you're not
yeah that's sorry the whole thing's in
Russian I don't know why but it actually
that's why we haven't met by the way it
turns out that I'm not infected I don't
believe you for one second Leon the Bell
Swanson if you think Batman this is
flashbacks all over the place
sorry I'm talking over the Russian but
I'm assuming that the majority of you
can't understand anyway so please read
the subtitles pay very close attention
to the subtitles
notification from the main core the
shelter came on my computer will someone
summon an expedition searching for
survivors right now that's probably not
good sending a signal all computers in
the station like you don't lose hope and
immediately move to them okay so very
much that will finally meet and then I'm
going to kiss you good luck I'm sure it
helped you before you're dead you're
very dead you're exceptionally dead if
I'm not mistaken this is taking place
exactly after the end of Black Plague so
it's trying to forget Requiem - oh those
like being up on the world leaders -
yelling yet dynamo Capri girl attaboy in
local custom one can say is the best
result is yellow
Donald's Babu he's using Ebola okay buy
a new pair - Lola leaving a bassoon
elder watch deleted like this - thank
you juicy oddball a new Inca Jewish is
like isn't our study Marty scrap it when
I expressed usual you were okay
what he's referring to is the end of
Black Plague and if you haven't seen it
it's okay but there are gonna be some
spoilers to it obviously if you're
watching this um the the thing is at the
end of Black Plague there was this guy
in my head that kept calling me monkey
my head is still spinning where did
Clarence come from his anima bel really
alive these questions didn't leave my
mind not even for a second there's one
thing that is perfectly clear I'm alive
and I've got a chance for salvation now
at the end of it there was this guy in
my head that was an infection from like
an alien or something that was kept
calling me monkey and his name was
Clarence or something like that and I
don't know either way that's all besides
up on the last play now if you didn't
know or if you couldn't tell this is
actually a case devotional decision I
had all summer the grunting mongoose
Kazak story Caledonia's can please me
nice huh the weapon grab your shoe could
be smashing yeah yeah dumb kid pure rock
okay oh boy a shiny penny and thank you
for complimenting on my riding ability I
take great pleasure in my ability to
ride anyway this guy was [ __ ] with me
and now he's saying that he's [ __ ]
with me again and Emma Belle who is
probably very dead I'm pretty hundred
percent sure that MFL is dead because
spoiler alert
I killed her accidental
hi although I thought that was that dot
was a flat site that's why mouse pointer
hello oh good good
what oh okay I thought something was
behind me I saw the very important thing
but I thought something else is there
okay so that guy got crushed yeah I
remember man this is so cool
oh so many flashbacks oh man I really
like the penumbra series it was really
exceptionally well done I mean it was
frictional games first foray in the
horror and it wasn't as popular as
amnesia I don't think it came at the
right time that's not because it was
wasn't scary or something like that it
was exceptionally scary ok that wasn't
for that it was exceptionally scary
black peg being more scary than um
overture by far but still both of them
were incredibly well made games and
really skub gave a frictional games a
nope all right then really game
frictional games a foothold into horror
hopefully ah
I gotcha [ __ ] alright oh wait a minute
I remember it saying nope every time it
did something that it didn't like me to
do oh I was so cool everything is like
oh is that Chloe okay I thought that was
glue okay so I got rope what can I do
with rope oh hello Hill ah get out of
here pills here oh how proud Lucas
Lucius loop what Larry oh god why can't
I remember his name
TF new guy Frank Francis Lewis da God
it's been a long time since I played the
original left 4 dead ah
hi someone there okay okay so I got
flashlight batteries in a rope I'm
assuming to the rope kimete hi
someone actually there you just
whispering sweet nothings into my ear
Kemah simming that I can use a rope yeah
we go okay how do i how do I uh so how
do I uh won't tell me how do i oh here
we go whoo all right all righty then
this looks good oh god I know what I
wanted to do I didn't want to do that
did I die
hello oh okay oh I slipped and I fell I
slipped and I fell real far and hurt my
bum bum
I wish tiny bugs Dibble here okay oh hi
you're dead you're very dead did you
fall - did you die from a bum bum energy
dam from what height did I fall my leg
swelled up I think it's broken I can't
walk a couple of my ribs are broken I
fell from a cliff all bypassing the area
there's a terrible storm and I it seems
I was blown off by the wind I can't
remember well a ladder is lying nearby
it's obviously fallen here the same way
as I have blah blah blah extremely cold
barely feel my limbs out of despair I
started looking for advantages and found
them the pain is almost in appreciable
blood flow bad this doesn't seem good
day for crawled into a corner patch of
thin ice Foley I could break it I would
not feel so cold um add stuff okay he's
sorry to his wife or his mother sick
father ooh sorry sorry rose TBS let's
throw that yeah hey I see Jeff
I'd rather not well I mean I'd look nice
there he's not exactly a handsome man I
would say oh so many memories of
penumbra oh my god
if anyone recalls I played penumbra
before I even had a webcam or anything
like that now this is just a demo this
isn't the full game so I'll be playing
it all in one episode ah no matter how
long it is I'll just be playing it in
one song hello deep dark oh uh okay it's
getting deeper and deeper oh yeah it is
at some moment I've started to think
that this faculty is endless the
facility my hope begin to fade I found
myself where I've never been before
whatever awaits me there remains to be
seen
it's so like but number did I say that
this was made as a custom a full
conversion mod to amnesia so and I
believe that amnesia and penumbra are
actually made on the same engine it's
just that I am Nisha is much more
refined and some edits to the engine all
together
ok don't need the flashlight right now I
got to be very conservative I imagine
they're not gonna give me very much
whatever I press the radio still doesn't
work soldering iron no am I gonna fix
this radio up mmm
shadows lovely I like it I like it a lot
can I open this no but I see things in
there okay all right nothing is
happening nothing ooh hello ah wire okay
so I can fix up this radio if I get
enough supplies as that house is gonna
go freezing cold I don't know where the
tunnel 'is lower the water level all
right I'll play your game you row
it's jammed its does that move into his
okay so I'm moving okay so I got the UM
the thing in the thong I decide make a
thingy thong you how do I think song it
up how do I do dang OOP no not quite
right yeah uh uh what made me think they
go together oh I don't know mr. sass I
would you go shove a piece of wire up
your butt oh really
that door was open a bull the whole time
I was just an idiot oh what a big
surprise okay blood stain leading off
into that door that's rich okay how
about nope
oh just block this up with my good old
trusty chair thank you very much for
doing stuff there's something reassuring
about that feeling like I've got one
less thing to worry about
well feeling that thing behind that door
whatever the hell it is okay pills oh no
wait that's capacitor okay so I am gonna
be building something opening of shelter
station reopened her ray because pay is
a very simple life it's bigger fixing
pipes um
feels good to lie in bed after hard
day's work for days since the opening of
the station um fails to fake sorry it's
been so long up too busy back in the
mine collapse incinerator I remembered
everything memories the beginning of
works I along with other poor souls of
the old military mines real big mines
no one knew is there something important
here that I need um voice appeared in my
head okay so you're infected and you
read ah read read I actually met the
voice actor for red that was really cool
um
point out the I'll go the station ah he
also does a voice for dr. kleiner in
Black Mesa that's where I I knew him
okay okay I've already done that yeah
yeah okay more pills
pink aha cable so I got all this junk I
can actually make something ate in China
in 1998 oh what's that
there's something up there no I need
more batteries I'm running out of
batteries real quick I need to be a bit
more conservative about it oh uh that is
one door I don't mind being locked yeah
you and me both buddy okay so I got a
bunch of stuff so can I do it now can I
create something
how about OOP how about how about you be
a little less sassy ah maybe I'm trying
to be inventive and create something
nice
ah there we go I just need to do oh
that's it okay
all right I got it I got it okay oh I
still need more components still need
more thing thong he's for the radio all
right I'll rush around and find it oh
wait Boop
ah [ __ ] there we go finally got it the
radio is exactly what I eager to get for
a long time just contact someone um need
a few components cuz it was faulty
something in here yeah baby
rawson Hey okay no not quite right oh
come on oh my go perfect
I did yes smart I'm smart big brain
hey hey slashed on your board
Hey Ya backdoor guardian
yeah I'm still away how many words
okay name one things like when choice
listen up in your [ __ ] room does that
red is that red might that actually be
red no you haven't
no please no yes mother you're slow I
nearly she caught you 20 McNulty you
scare thanks Clarence my story TV
nikasha Staton Apollo video squeezy
trots ooh baby TBC dis video
scatterradio a testigos or Stamos vogue
resume itza attention protects nian so
am prayin prima otama loss Pagar a basis
to achieve Ashley a road key no splatter
zone esto in a shirt curious of tweak
Mosca yeah picanha pi muchos Rhea
Petrucelli Libya so Erica's an arena
uh-huh janosh not a curio shop at
impossible choice yet or drugs a
Buddhist Oh Stella can be pushy titrate
dahlias Vince's good me new problem
yeah okay thanks uncle Clarence you're
just the best yeah I don't think it'd be
a good idea to take this off what the
hell was that that was it
is there something actually there hello
my name is markiplier I'm here to help
kind of oh hello
ah all right now we're making some
progress where are we going is the
question that doesn't open that won't
budge but this is partly open just a
small stain of blood nothing to worry
about
hello the whole heating water supply
system is checked nothing will go day
goes without a failure pipes leaking
wiring began to fail many workers going
mad okay so the workers started to go
insane I think I picked that up the last
time the nose playing they also started
to be infected by alien zombies and
turned into gigantic monsters right oh
come on it's alright whenever these are
always awkward to open when I move my
mouse a certain way it doesn't only go
there we go
all right down into the green goo that
hears him
down into the green glowing goop it's
always a good thing
didn't they actually expect that to open
oh okay so I'm back here let's just
leave that closed for now all right I
don't see a bottom I shouldn't dive
there oh well too bad I really wanted to
dive um okay so what's the point of that
oh I'm in the water room oh of course
dah dah dah dah dah there we go
water go down want to go down
that's a reassuring sound for the water
to go down to alright oh goodness
red eye I preferred green actually red
green did anyone watch the red green
show okay so oh I guess I got to go down
in here okay so now whoa didn't mean to
do that
take it off oh I don't feel so good
Oh give him my arms and legs there we go
I'll bet oh man no water moss is here
gotta remember there are no water
muscles here now
although I am these a machine for pigs
oh hey I remember you with the not so
penis like thing coming out of your
belly button there we determined that it
was not a penis after careful study okay
so is this uh missing part to something
important something I need some someone
needs does anybody need this seems kind
of important I don't know I'm just
assuming ah butter ski BAM [ __ ] so what
did that do actually no anyway um what
was I saying about even though I am the
CEO machine for pigs takes place in the
same universe as amnesia the first one
because it's an indirect sequel it's not
a hundred percent if penumbra is in
relation to the world of amnesia I where
where was I going I have no idea okay
did that help drain the rest of this no
so what did that do oh there might have
been another part okay I might in
another piece of the puzzle
all right must lower the water level I'm
assuming ky2 splashes oh I had a
brainwave okay maybe when I put that
there
I'd go back up and crank the truth yeah
it's green in here why didn't I realize
that I sorry I didn't notice that okay
so then I can turn it again and drain
the water out of the main place okay
good good good good good good alright
yeah baby
that's the stuff okay making progress
making bacon going into the dark cuz I'm
just about out of juice so where am I
going
wait what was the point of this
oh okay I see sorry I didn't even know
that I'm not seeing things in front of
my face I'm not thinking logically okay
any creepy monsters that want to kill me
in order to open the door you must enter
a specific number each technician has
his own combination it means it's safe
words cannot enter for Xavier isn't keep
the disk with the password safe all
right so where's the disk that is the
question need some sort of tool to get
this up and how about a trashcan lid Oh
chair nope all right then fine that's
how it's gonna be locked prolly need
input a key code it what's that nothing
there's got to be something over here
there's gonna be some kind of B oh
what's that oh it's damn nevermind sorry
my mistake my bad
ah there we go oh it's an air oh nothing
I'm getting everyone that was false
alarm everybody ha ha whoa is that tiny
bugs Tim oh no you're just an impostor
an impostor I can't even pick up you
made me think you were my friend I'm
wondering if this old key goes to a door
back here it might might wait work oh my
flash I just ran out of batteries
no not quite right oh I know what door
it goes to oh boy
fine sigil you're real I thought you
might have been a [ __ ] but your real
point editor
oh I'm not doing so good oh I'm not
doing so good yeah what'd I do ah what
do I do
FBI what do I do Oh what do I do add
some in my eye
ow oh I'm infected oh okay so why did I
need to unlock that for him to bash it
down with his fissile no oh I remember
you oh I remember all about you oh thank
you no is there
oh my I am I don't even know them
good God okay you want a barrel oh yeah
you like that you [ __ ]
sure I'm spitting everywhere I don't
have any battery left oh oh oh yeah yeah
you heard that right you heard that
noise it was a noisy noise very
suspicious don't come back in here
alrighty grab her that's what I needed
Oh something is in my eye no no no no no
no no no no no no no dodo oh okay I oh
my eye
okay alright now I can get this off ah
so the description says looks as if it's
been used for almost everything say for
what it's meant for
oh so it's done some screwing in its day
huh that's what okay funk
oh no okay I thought that was stuck for
a second there alright going into the
dark tunnel with no flashlights can I
can I please there we go
I can't see anything Oh level transition
oh okay ooh excuse me as I go through
puberty for a real squid second hey that
was the demo there we having everybody
there you go
how'd you like it now this game is still
in development from from what I've seen
so far that is very faithful to penumbra
I mean it brought back a lot of memories
for me so I hope you guys enjoyed it
it's very well done it's very well true
to the original in amnesia hurry and
penumbra like I felt like I was playing
penumbra again it should be very fun so
go support the up the mod right now you
can click the link in the description
there's one that links straight to the
mod page
I'll give them a shout out they
obviously worked real hard on this and
it's really well done so thank you all
so much for watching thank you
making this game and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye hello
everybody and welcome to part one of
let's play a number of overture I
understand the first game is a serious
Oh bat not me
okay normal I don't want to die too much
that's what people are whatever
story began in February
bud
after you